SHULKIN IS NOT GOING QUIETLY
TONIGHT.
HE'S GOING PUBLIC WITH HIS MANY
GRIEVANCES.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT HIM LIVE IN A
MOMENT.
BUT FIRST, LUCAS TOMLINSON AT
THE PENTAGON ON SHULKIN'S
PARTING SHOTS AGAINST THE
WASHINGTON CULTURE.
GOOD EVENING.
>> BRET, PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS IN
OHIO TODAY TO DEFEND THE FIRING
OF HIS VETERANS AFFAIRS
SECRETARY DR. DAVID SHULKIN.
>> I WASN'T HAPPY WITH THE SPEED
WITH WHICH OUR VETERANS WERE
TAKEN CARE OF.
WE MADE CHANGES BECAUSE WE WANT
THEM TAKEN CARE OF.
WE WANT THEM TO HAVE CHOICE.
SO THAT THEY CAN RUN TO A
PRIVATE DOCTOR.
>> SHULKIN WASN'T TOO HAPPY
ABOUT GETTING AXED AND TOOK OUT
HIS FRUSTRATIONS IN A BLISTERING
OP ED THIS MORNING SAYING
"WASHINGTON HAS TURNED SO TOXIC,
CHAOTIC, DISRESPECTFUL AND
SUBVERSIVE THAT IT BECAME
IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME TO ACCOMPLISH
THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT OUR
VETERANS NEED."
THE FORMER SECRETARY BLAMED
CRITICS FOR MAKING FALSE
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST HIM.
THEY SAW ME AS AN OBSTACLE TO
PRIVATIZATION.
HIS REMOVAL BOILED OVER
FOLLOWING AN ETHICS SCANDAL, HE
WAS QUICK TO POINT OUT HIS
SUCCESSES.
EXPANDING ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
REDUCING WAIT TIMES AND WORKING
CLOSER WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
SHULKIN SAYS THE PERCENTAGE OF
VETERANS WHO REGAINED TRUST IN
THE V.A. HAS RISEN FROM 46% FOUR
YEARS AGO TO 74% TODAY.
STILL, HE STRUGGLED TO WIN OVER
CONGRESS AND EVEN VETS.
>> YOU LED ME TO BELIEVE THAT
YOU AND I WERE ON THE SAME PAGE.
OUR INABILITY TO REACH AN
AGREEMENT IS IN SIGNIFICANT PART
RELATED TO YOUR ABILITY TO SPEAK
OUT OF BOTH SIDES OF YOUR MOUTH.
DOUBLE TALK.
>> SARAH'S HUSBAND HAS MANY MORE
THAN 100 SURGERIES SINCE BEING
WOUNDED IN AFGHANISTAN.
SHE SAYS SHE'S READY FOR CHANGE.
>> WE NEED A SECRETARY IN THERE
WHO IS EMPOWERING AND ENACTING
THE PRESIDENT'S PLAN.
IT'S A SYSTEM THAT NEEDS MASSIVE
AND TOTAL OVERHAUL.
IT'S A STAIN ON OUR NATION AND
WE OWE THESE HEROES SO MUCH
MORE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NOMINEE TO
REPLACE SHULKIN, ADMIRAL RONNIE
JACKSON.
>> SOME PEOPLE HAVE JUST GREAT
GENES.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE PHYSICIAN
BEST KNOWN AS A DOCTOR WHO
DELIVERED THE BRIEFING ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PHYSICAL IS
ALREADY COMING UNDER FIRE FOR
HIS CREDENTIALS.
SOME QUESTION WHETHER THE NAVY
DOCTOR CAN SUCCESSFULLY LEAD THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S SECOND
LARGEST DEPARTMENT.
THE OLDEST WAR VETERANS
ORGANIZATION SAYING "DR.
JACKSON'S BIO DOES NOT REFLECT
ANY EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH THE
V.A. OR WITH VETERANS OR
MANAGING ANY ORGANIZATION OF
THIS SIZE."
ON MONDAY, ACTING V.A. SECRETARY
ROBERT WILKE TAKES OVER ON AN
INTERIM BASIS.